in any case uh lee Kaplan came to my
attention because he was looking at the
activities of what is called the
international
solidarity uh movement the
ism and I noticed that there were
some assorted people very very leftwing
Marxist
oriented Islamic activists involved in
this and loow and behold SS and Dorne as
well nobody has done the research into
this movement which is very very
powerful and threatening even more
International incidents in the coming
months uh than Lee Kaplan let me give
you a little bit about him before he
comes up here he is an investigative
journalist who's been published around
the world world including in a front
page magazine Israel national news
Canada Free Press uh his columns appear
in other websites as well the Northeast
intelligence Network campus watch he's
heading the organizations including
defending America for knowledge and
action and stop the ism ISM meaning
International solidarity movement he
appears regularly on radio and TV incl
in on the Fox News Channel and he's a
graduate of UCLA on the uh bruan Alumni
Association and the UCLA Alumni
Association and writes extensively about
the Middle East Lee
Ka before I start I want to thank cff
for having me uh come and speak and
actually what he's doing here with his
organization I think is vitally
important there's a lot of things going
going on in the world and the country
today which is just below the radar and
people don't know about it and it's
people like Cliff uh I was very happy to
meet people like Pam Geller who's going
to talk to you next who are bringing to
the Forefront this information and
hopefully the people in this room when
they learn these things they'll go out
and they'll spread it how many people
here are familiar with my work or know
about the ism Okay so we've got maybe
three hands which is which is an
interesting thing I've been writing
about this sh organization and it's uh
it's hard to actually say it's an
organization for the last seven years
the ism is actually not an individual
card carrying organization what it is is
a
Consortium of various Marxist leninist
organizations affiliated with the
Islamic uh Jihad around the world now
one of the interesting things and how
this ties in with Al jazer is uh one of
the fears that I'm sure Cliff has
related to Al jazer is how subterfuge
will be used by AR uh Al jazer in terms
of
propaganda people don't understand that
the ism since 2001 has been actively
engaged in all manner of subterfuge in
our universities in our libraries in our
textbooks in our churches in our labor
unions that people in this country have
very little idea about and it's only
getting worse and worse and worse we are
right now in in a city which has uh more
or less the centralized location for the
international solidarity movement they
call themselves now the US campaign to
end the Israeli
occupation and they're based here in
Washington DC they represent
320 islamist Marxist leninists and other
organizations whose real goal is first
the destruction of Israel yes but Israel
is the canary in the mine the first step
towards bringing all of their Anarchist
activities to the United States and to
the Mexican border which I'll explain as
we move along when we talk about a
threat from Al
jazer I want to I want to tell uh you
people about a Smoking Gun that just
came out over the weekend just before I
flew here to Washington to speak there
was a letter through the Freedom of
Information Act which came out in uh UC
Irvine they have a program there called
The Olive Tree initiative
and the program was set up by one of the
co-founders of the ism this is a former
pflp terrorist well terrorist member of
the
pflp and he has a a an organization in
Pasadena California called The Holy Land
Trust now for years what he has done is
he has created study [__] abroad programs
where he went to uh uh colleges and he
got public money to send students over
ostensibly for for peaceful dialogue in
the Middle East but what they were
really doing was sending ISM activists
these are the people that rioted the
security fence over in the Middle East
and they were sending them over there
with public money in order to Riot and
to promote the causes of the terrorist
groups and act as human shields for the
terrorist
groups eventually what happened was he
managed to start a group called The
Olive Tree
initiative which he got in at UC Irvine
and he got public money now the
subterfuge and this is the same threat
that we would have with Al jazer the
subut was so good was that he was
putting together uh you know a peace and
dialogue program he was going to bring
Jewish Christian and Muslim Students
together from UC Irvine and bring them
over to the West Bank and they were
going to discuss ways to make peace in
the Middle East well what they did was
they brought them over there and they
brought them to speak to people like
Diana Buu who's the lawyer for the PLO
Miss Buu gives presentations where she
tells them that the kasum rockets that
are fired by Hamas into Israel don't
have warheads on them they were lectured
by George rashma where they were told
that Israeli soldiers shoot Palestinian
children for fun and for target
practice now as incredible as this might
seem a lot of the Jewish kids were
coming back and were participating on
the boycott of Israel on the college
campuses and what's even more amazing is
the Jewish
Federation was helping to fund the
program now we have a woman named D
Sterling back there who uh found out
about this she's from South Africa and
uh she started trying to complain about
it Jewish Federation actually put
together a fake Petition of students at
UC Irvine that they fabricated who
proven I've urged her to sue the
university and and uh H Hillel the
Jewish organization on campus put
together a faked petition by the
students to vilify her anyway through
the Freedom of Information Act we just
obtained a letter which just came out on
the internet a couple of days ago in
which it turns out that the Jewish
Federation this is an organization which
is supposed to be pro-israel and against
terrorist organizations like Hamas knew
that the Olive Tree initiative was
taking students to meet with the leader
of
Hamas in violation of us anti-terrorism
laws it's against the law for them to
meet with humus if you read the report
which Cliff has put together for you to
read about the international solidarity
movement you'll see the names of people
like Scott Kennedy or Paul arudy or ha
to ARA these are US citizens in the
United States which are on a daily basis
raising money for Hamas for the
terrorist organization they put together
the money for the flotillas the
flotillas that were in the news for
example the Maui M mamaro which was
attacked by uh which the Israeli
soldiers were attacked on that was the
seventh flotilla that went there it
really amused me how President Obama uh
said I want an investigation about this
well the fact of the matter is uh uh I
have an interview on the Israel national
news where I came over there and on
Israel TV I said uh yeah let's do an
investigation the flotillas are
organized put together and completely
funded right here in the United States
most of it's done in San Francisco where
I where I come from in my my
baileywick and we are funding this war
against
ourselves that's one of the things uh
that relates to is zero because what we
are doing is we are
providing tax-free money to be raised by
nonprofits all over the country which
are part of the international solidarity
movement which violate their their their
mandates from the IRS I've written
articles in which I've gotten some of
these companies audited and gotten their
their uh tax fre status removed
interestingly enough George Soros
created something called groundspring
which due to the LAX City and the uh
nonprofit laws allows them to still
raise the money tax-free but all this
money is being raised and it's being
raised to help groups like Hamas the
pflp Islamic Jihad and assorted
terrorist
organizations now give you a little bit
about information about me well how do
you know all this Lee how do you get
involved with this again it's only three
people in the room know who I am um
I uh I became an investigative
journalist about eight years ago and uh
how I got involved with the ism was I uh
was told about an ism training session
where they were recruiting activists to
go over and participate with rioting and
interference with the Israeli Army on
the West Bank and what I did was I dyed
my hair black and I dyed my eyebrows
black and I colored my skin and I went
in as a
Pakistani I did an accent I used to be
an actor in my 20s a million years ago
and uh uh I attended their training
session I had hidden cameras I took
pictures of everybody I recorded the
whole training session and believe it or
not when I had all that information and
I had a full report I took it to the
Israeli
consulate and they slammed the door in
my face and the reason why they slammed
the door in my face I'm sure is that
they didn't want to be accused of spying
on American
citizens however I turned the report
over to the intelligence Services over
in Israel every one of those ISM
activists was arrested when they got to
Israel the leader and trainer of the
group they actually had a communist
attorney in Israel who was trying to get
her into the country because she was of
Jewish descent which I'll touch on Jews
in the ism later
on ultimately my report was used as
evidence in the Israeli Supreme Court
and she was deported
also since that that time I've devoted
the last eight years mainly to going
undercover at ISM conferences and
functions in the United States
especially at us college campuses I can
tell you that I have actually gone to
seminars where they talk about how to
put a good face on suicide bombings how
did deconstruct in the American Market
opposition to
terrorism uh I attended at one session
in Ohio state was a young woman named
Fatima aayu who was a student right here
at Georgetown she was planning to go to
work in the US state department I
believe it was my exposes and my
contacts with the government that
ultimate ultimately prevented her from
doing that oddly enough today this
recent graduate from college is now on
the board of directors of Human Rights
Watch so you know you have this
infiltration going on and you might say
well it's just freedom of speech I mean
aren't they allowed to put out their
point of view well let me put it to you
this way if you look at the Second World
War
England was more or less the aircraft
carrier for the United States against
the Germans on the uh European continent
and we have the same situation with
Israel today now over the years I've
attended ISM conferences which are
usually held at American universities
and the reason why they're held at the
universities is because they are
taxpayer supported institutions so any
dollars that are put into these projects
at the taxpayer institutions usually get
matched by the
taxpayer and at these things they do all
all manner of advertising which is
actually not just against Israel but
also against our troops overseas
supporting the enemies now if you read
the report that Cliff has handed out to
you it mentions media Benjamin in global
exchange how many people here know about
media Benjamin in global exchange all
right so we've got maybe three people
out of the entire room and I know Pam
knows who she is all right media
Benjamin uh is is a uh she was born
Jewish her real name is Susie Benjamin
it makes you wonder about a woman who
would change her name to Media who
murdered her own children Greek
mythology but she started the group
global exchange which is a nonprofit in
the San Francisco Bay Area she's
actually managed to appear even on Bill
O'Reilly's show and underneath her name
it says peace activist she's not a peace
activist she's a lifelong Marxist
communist she spent four years living
with Fidel Castro which she considers
Cuba the best years of her life of
course she lives in Berkeley California
now
and she raises tons and tons of
money aside from money that she may be
getting from Arab interest she gets
money also from all the 60s leftists
antiwar people everything from back back
in the60s and she runs nonprofit
businesses called Global Exchange in the
Bay
Area during uh the Battle of fuia when
we had our Marines losing their arms and
legs fighting in Iraq she sent with the
permission of our government I might add
600 00,000
in Aid quote to the Iraqi resistance not
to the Iraqi poor which they claimed it
was medical supplies for the for the
civilians but to the Iraqi resistance
she was allowed to spend
$600,000 to the enemy in time of War can
you imagine during World War II somebody
sending $600,000 to the Nazi regime even
in medical supplies actually those
medical supplies are sold on the black
market that's where the money goes but
you know can you imagine during World
War II anything like that taking place
and this is the same situation and
threat that you have with Al jazer
because this is just another form of of
Suter Fusion now the report is pretty
extensive that I've got here and I urge
all of you to read it one of the things
I talk about in here is title six how
many people here know what title six
funding is not one of you okay title six
funding was set up in
1959 by the US Congress during the Cold
War and the purpose of title six was to
provide tax dollars to the universities
so that they could have Russian study
programs students uh who were funded by
title 6 and departments that were funded
by title 6 could teach Russian so there
would be translators and people to deal
with the Cold War and they were also
taught about Russian
culture immediately after 911 you have
James abek who was a former Senator he's
from
Wisconsin and uh he also belongs to an
organization called the council for the
national interest which I'm sure nobody
here knows about also they used to be a
Neo-Nazi organization now they are a
Saudi funded
organization also working with the ism
who also Advocate uh you know U not
supporting Israel in the Middle
East the the title 6 money that was then
designated was sent out to the colleges
all across the United States I have an
article on the web called the Saudi
fifth column on us
campuses that title 6 money went to set
at Middle East studies centers at all
the campuses but instead of teaching
Arabic instead of promoting us interest
during the war on terror they went out
and they hired which courtesy of the
Middle East countries which were also
getting into the colleges by donating
money to the colleges they hired
professors who were decidedly anti- us
and
anti-israel so you actually had for
example I have an article called
Scholars for Terror on the web which you
can find
and in it I had a national meeting of
the Middle East studies Association this
was like attending a session of al-
Qaeda in the United States you had Not
only was it anti-israel not only did it
have non-academics at it promoting the
end of Israel but they also had
professors there advocating for the
other side during the war against Saddam
Hussein this is all subterfuge and it's
all under the level and you say well how
could how could in the Middle East how
could they get somebody to strap a bombb
on himself and blow himself up he must
be so desperate he must be so starving
it isn't that it's the indoctrination
that they experienced from the time
they're three years old in
school and the same thing is starting to
happen over here because our colleges
since about 2001 when they first started
with the ism this actually goes back
with the colleges into the
1990s began this this subterfuge program
with the Middle East study centers which
also contain breath requirement classes
that students take now as a journalist
I'm a sorry breath breath requirements
in other words you have to take the
class to get your
degree one of the things as an under
cover journalist that I did was I
enrolled in a college course at Diablo
Valley Community College near me in San
Francisco I went in and the course was
taught by an
imom he was teaching the hamus
charter now he didn't call it the hamus
charter to the class but he was teaching
from mamas CH he was teaching from a
charter from terrorist
organization and uh when I would call
him and question on things on in the
charter he didn't know I was a
journalist at one point he tried to kick
me out of the class and when I went to
the dean the next day and the dean said
I heard you've been making trouble in
class and I told him I was a journalist
the dean almost peed in his
pants I can tell you that the class was
canceled just for that semester he's
back now teaching at Diablo Valley
College American government
and he's also teaching at San Francisco
State University too so he he's moved
up
um one of the things I want to get clear
and I want on the record here at this uh
uh at this speech is that there are
certain people who are leaders of the
ism in the United States who must be put
in
prison one of them is a man named Paul
Ludi who was in the San Francisco Bay
Area I have pictures of him here in the
uh in the report that Cliff is handing
out and I urge you all to get a copy of
it Paul arudy if you actually go through
the report there are photographs of Paul
arudy shaking hands with the leaders of
hamus he was part of the Gaza flotilla
and receiving gold
medals from the hamus
leadership another man is named Scott
Kennedy who was the mayor of s Santa
Cruz California he has an organization
which is part of the ism called the
resource center for
nonviolence which is also taxfree raises
money called the escaton
foundation uh he also there are pictures
of him here in Gaza marching with hus
terrorists now what these people do is
against the law but our government and I
don't care if you're Republican or
Democrat does not enforce the
law you all probably know that President
Obama just gave another $550 million
ostensibly to Gaza and to hamus and the
West Bank now they don't say it's for
hamus they say it's for non-governmental
organizations but these non-governmental
organizations are all run by Hamas and
the money is fungible once it gets over
there and it's in the Arab bank account
you have no way of knowing what's going
on with it now you say how are they
doing this subterfuge what does this got
to do with alir well let me explain how
they got into the colleges here in the
United States they started an
organization the PLO did called pasia
the Palestinian academic Society for the
study of international Affairs I talk
about it in the
report what pasia does is it takes Arab
students Palestinian students who have a
good command of English and they send
them to colleges All Over America they
don't let them pick where they go to
school and they let up pick what they're
going to major in but they give them a
chance to have a US education at the
same time they they are assigned to get
on the student newspapers they're
assigned to do those weekly
demonstrations I don't know how many of
you go to a college campus every week
but almost every week lately you'll see
a checkpoint demonstration or an Israeli
apartheid week demonstration or
something like this this is all
organized this is not a Grassroots thing
this is all organized
abroad in fact uh we just managed to get
a lawsuit started at UC Berkeley where a
Jewish student was assaulted by one of
the members of the students for justice
in Palestine there one of the things
they did was use information for one of
my articles in which I I brought out
pictures showing uh these students
carrying machine guns on campus and
stopping students on their way to class
and telling them well this is what it's
like in
Israel you know they constantly break
the
law and the government doesn't do
anything about it part of it has to be
has to come from saudy influence part of
it comes from money part of it's just
lazy on the part of the government but
bringing in Al jazer is just
another another weapon in what they're
doing in fact some of the correspondents
that I've seen on Al jazer television
have been ISM activists who later got a
job with Al jazer because they speak
English and they'll do the propaganda
for
them how much time do we have um minutes
okay
um as I started to say there are two
people I want you people to go on the
internet when you uh when you go home
one her name is ha ARA it's h u w AI
da a r r a
f now she is one of the co-founders of
the international solidarity
movement she is also the person one of
the two key people who organized the
flotillas which uh have been in the news
creating International incidents related
to Israel and hamus
the other one is Paul
Ludi both of these people are constantly
raising money for the flotillas and they
do it in violation of their 501c3
mandates and the
IRS looks the other
way whether it's because they don't
understand the Israeli Palestinian
conflict or they don't want to get
involved or they just don't care or is
from pressure from up in the white house
I can't say but I can tell you that they
constantly do it at one point when I
wrote about some of these organizations
they took away their nonprofit status
but they found other ways to get around
the corner by running it through another
nonprofit if you go to the website for
the US campaign to end the Israeli
occupation you'll see they have 320 ISM
Affiliated groups across the United
States and they call themselves
different things they're in the churches
they have seil ecumenical society which
passes itself off as a Christian
organization which wants Israel well
dismantled and preaches a new theology
the American Library Association has a
uh a group in it that promotes uh uh uh
Marxist leninist ideology but also
promotes the Palestinian cause and they
promoted textbooks in your public
libraries and your school
libraries you can uh uh you can even
find Jewish organizations that they have
managed to infiltrate now I went to uh
uh conferences in Ohio State at Duke
University University and each one I was
disguised most of the time I was
disguised I look like an Arab or a
Taliban but the fact is I got into
planning meetings as crazy as it sounds
that I made myself up to look like that
I got into planning meetings and I
listened and they actually had sessions
where they talked about how to
infiltrate Jewish groups in the United
States with the purpose of
deconstructing American Jewish support
for
Israel now the best
example ISM conf yeah ISM conferences
they called them pal solidarity
conferences ultimately uh give you an
example of how successful they've been
with that they had a film festival the
Jewish Film Festival in San Francisco
and Paul arudy was actually there and
the room was filled with ISM activists
and they were supposedly passing
themselves off as members of the Jewish
Community they actually got Jewish funds
to bring Rachel Corey's mother to watch
an anti-israel film screen about
supposedly how her daughter was murdered
now if you go on the web and you look at
a website called stinky
journalism. you'll see that in
2006 I debunked the whole Rachel Corey
uh death
story in which it was maintained that
she was murdered by the Israelis by a
bulldozer killing her when she stood in
front of a Palestinian home she was
killed by a bulldozer in a combat zone
however I show how they manipulated
photographs and Photoshop now there's a
trial going on in Israel right now that
I was called in as an expert to help the
IDF they established in the trial
already that she was not killed
protecting a house yet the US campaign
to end the Israeli occupation is putting
out emails and has on their website
today a big solicitation for donations
give us money to uh Sue Israel and go
after Israel and demonstrate on the
campuses and do all this stuff because
Rachel Corey was killed protecting a
Palestinian home well she wasn't killed
Pro protecting a Palestinian home she
was a Palestinian uh advocate in the ism
an anarchist and actually I have a
recording
of one of the ismr who was with her in
which he admits that they were there
helping acting as human shields for the
armed terrorist to draw fire on Israeli
soldiers but none of this is getting out
in the
media what we doing on time okay well
I'll wrap it up I'll wrap it up now I've
just scratched the surface here because
like I say I've got eight years of this
stuff but you know the international
solidarity movement I believe is a
bigger threat than the armed terrorists
because what they've done in the last
eight years is they've gotten into
every social aspect of American society
they are in the colleges they are in the
libraries they are in the unions they
are in the tech Al jazer this campaign
with Al jazer this is all part of a
grand plan and at the session at Duke
University I attended one of their
leaders had a session and he said the
purpose of all that we're doing and all
the rioting we do in the West Bank at
the security fence and all that stuff is
training and practice practice to bring
it to the US border with Mexico and ISM
leaders have actually met with
commandante subcomandante Marcos who is
the head of the zapatistas in Mexico
anybody here ever hear the zapatistas it
is a Mexican terrorism gang they are
meeting with the
zapatistas if you read the news you see
about the riots that the ism conducts
against the security fence they call it
an apartheid wall which is which is a
total uh uh bastardization of the
purpose of the fence cuz it keeps out
suicide bers they are planning to do
that here on the Mexican border anyway I
urge you to look at the report if
anybody has questions for me outside
I'll be glad to talk to
you all
right we're going to um um take a break
now uh because we want to make sure we
end on up on time and that we give
Pamela plenty of time and we have plenty
of time for the book signings later so
you can take this opportunity if you
want to ask Lee any questions during the
break we're going to take just five
minutes and then we'll be be back for uh
Pamela Geller so remember five minutes
back in your
seats
ch